A fellow knitter recently showed me
a ready-to-wear sweater
that she wanted to duplicate.
Now, anytime I look at sweaters
with my machine knitter's eye,
I put them to the test.
Can it be done?
Our machines have some limitations
and we need to keep these in mind.
Is it practical?
Some designs just don't lend
themselves to our knitting machines.
Sweaters knit in the round, for example.
Are you willing to do what it takes?
One knitter may find it great fun to hand
manipulate every square inch of a sweater.
Others, like me, prefer an easier route.
Let's take a look at the construction
of this sweater and consider
these three criteria.
This design is a fitted cardigan
in a tunic length with short sleeves.
It has empire styling and the soft
collar frames a very low V neck.
It's difficult to see the armholes
in the photo, but I'm guessing
it has set in sleeves.
It looks like the knitting is plain old
stockinette and it has ribbed hems
other than the collar.
It appears that this sweater
meets our first criteria.
Can it be done?
Sure.
The second criteria is,
is this design practical on the machine?
Now, it appears that the collar is
the only area that could be problematic.
Because of our needlebed limitations,
we couldn't knit the entire collar
and front bands in one piece.
Now that we've established that it's
possible, the big question is,
are you willing to do what it
takes to create this design?
First, are you willing to draft
the complete pattern from scratch or are
you willing to modify an existing pattern?
Here are some options.
You could start with a knit it now basic
pattern for a cardigan with set in sleeves
and use our tools to modify it to create
that V neck and the other
pieces of this pattern.
If you have DesignaKnit, you could create
the pattern shapes if you're so inclined.
You could draw the shapes to scale
based on the finished dimensions
of the sweater and create a design
for your knit leader or knit radar.
You could also find a hand or machine
knitting pattern that is close to this
shape and make changes for your design.
Do you have a ribber?
If not, the hems could be hand
manipulated or knit by hand.
Let's tackle the most difficult part of
this design, the collar and the neckband.
The easiest solution would be to pick up
and knit the collar and bands by hand.
Do you hand knit?
Are you willing to take time to do it?
Now, with a little planning,
we could knit the ribbed band
and the collar in multiple pieces.
It would be important to plan where
the seams would be placed
and notice that the collar is shaped.
It's wider at the center back,
so there would be some short
row shaping in the collar area.
Hmm.
Short rows in ribbing.
For me, creating this sweater would be
a fun challenge, especially
because I love to hand knit.
What about you?